we started in with the grounding the
ground right so you push this I'm going
to kneel with the other
wash your head you don't want to get
head butt in the face lower in the mat
not on the match you're too high
always too hard you don't want to pull
her we just work it on the first
yielding that part you're not doing get
in the back
don't parallel the line of attack enter
into it across it go to the back you're
parallel
[Music]
breathe in breath still counts
inhale pressurize
so I know I have this attack right and
I'm going to yield disappear so I'm
gonna do slow he's pushing right oh yeah
I'm gonna I'm going to yield so come
over there and push from this angle push
them in this segment and you can see
it's yielding from this angle it's not
yielding from all angles you guys
understand that all right so he's
pushing right and boom there's a yield
there but there's no yield
there's no yield here okay oh oh oh
he'll boom same thing on this hand
there's a yield from this angle when
he's coming here push there's no yield
there oh okay do you understand
are they don't confuse I'm here and is
it you home first we want them to move
we get a movie by yielding but you lose
not weakness
oh push heart heart heart heart heart
wish your Center
[Music]
push harder and I can't do it slow keep
pushing keep pushing keep pushing
push harder that's your drill slow he's
pushing hard
I'm just redirecting to the ground keep
the structure yielding I'll give you two
reps where you got to really push it you
get really exhausted
[Music]
breathe breathe
go round you you're kind of pulling him
we want him more entering because we're
not obstructing pipe
you're pulling her on the lefthand
intern step enter more around her and
you don't have to move her around you
good more if you keep your structure
your four corners lock it
pressurize pressurize keep it as you
move at the end you letter or you
release it all means launching hold it
hold the structure go hold it as you're
moving hold it as you're at the end
you're kind of pulling him
[Music]
awareness up for now
so that that's the first energy I want
right so I crowd and then I'm yielding
without losing my crown
hey you guys got it but okay so that's
why I don't want to pull him that's not
what energies I was working on I want as
much as possible to get whatever I need
from that it's not pulling be careful
because if you're pulling on his
fingertips even though you're looking
the same shape it's not the same shape
it's a progressive yielding push push
[Music]
you'll feel you'll feel okay I look like
going around
make sure your your your edenia she
isn't retreating so just right foot
don't step backwards on it do not dance
change dancing there's no easy be not
yet with a stance change
that's not entering its trading side
[Music]
lock your body
see where my foot is on battle on fire
tips so then I doing the yield and then
I could step back and then I steps back
to that people do that all over the
world because they they can't enter
there's too much pressure so they're off
gasoline and then the culture and he'll
fall for me I can do some adjustments
but my foot can't come all the other one
and my only two that push and I'm doing
everything if I take no - hi
no that's better
spread your fingers so you get a better
cook you boy so spread are you trained
denied exaggerate when you're training
have a straight arms
you want to free that shoulder more it's
not locked out of stiffness weight is
still on your heels you know when you
walk you walk when you wait on your
heels change your life change watch it
it doesn't condition you
it's from weakness to weakness breathe
three three three lower three too high
for you to drop your weight but I also
think you're trying to pick them up by
15 all right that's not how we do come
up you're doing this dance team and
you're going to remain weak you take
your pressure off you take plates off
the rock right
and you're not lifting that much yes
change you're taking pressure off the
edie me you'd say you're not
conditioning this is the hard way okay
don't don't move right I'm not you're
gonna want to do that just like when he
was pushing at you you wanted to push
him back well what is that an
oppositional force and it triggers an
oppositional force okay so here I have
to figure out don't come don't come here
I have to figure out how to get him to
move without pulling on anything all
right how do you do it hello I not going
to use his fingers that's
Hey so I'm going to start to shift him
look what I first doing mechanically to
his center of gravity here he's standing
over himself so by turning this my god I
gotta lean not see that okay so it's not
gonna happen
by me just getting out of the way push
hard push mark enemy hitting out of the
way that somebody you guys are doing
which is why I made that correction
about it's not weak okay so the same
thing here
I am NOT going like this just to get
that angle I am using his grip this is
how I want to train I'm using his grip
and I will feel myself want to pull him
and when you feel that I want you to
practice course pose okay so he course
was internally not course blow is
externally okay so he's there don't come
don't come
okay he's there and I will feel that I'm
going to use use his body then what I
feel like oh I almost got him and I
start pulling I don't want you to I
don't want you to pull them so the first
thing is you're doing that internally I
want you to understand mechanically what
you what you're doing to his posture
okay so I'll feel that let it go let it
go
Hey so again if he lets go any pushes
from this angle right it's not gonna
change so what how do you know that I'm
doing that alright so as I as I go like
this right go go go right angle relax
okay now watch my body is he's gonna do
the other trouble do the other drill
right do you see how changing okay so my
body you can look is is relaxed is
relaxed is relaxed and I'm not going to
move and he's gonna come push on this
bar no right here where you would think
no there's nothing
it's push right there's still nothing
there
but from this angle this angle right
yeah so soft soft don't pull don't pull
don't pull that little step that's my
task right now Oh a little bite okay
relax
don't think he'd eat me not yet think
I'm just doing a corpse pose game that's
all I'm doing
I'm checking my body for tension and I'm
releasing it that is all I'm doing don't
pull
checking for tension that is all you're
doing
[Music]
using his fingers as the temptation and
the catalyst for the relaxation your
goals not to get that step your goal is
to do the relaxation at any moment I
should be able to come by a push on you
and you're not gonna go collapsing and
flying across the mat so guess what's
happening next careful not to pull
[Music]
when I'm trying to do it I want us to be
stuck okay and I am sticking to him by
letting him by me staying perfectly in
the center of his fingers the thumb and
that and his fingers okay so if he if he
goes to push right you feel do you feel
the ground right you go push really hard
some people no okay and then so I'm
gonna stay inside his grip perfectly
neither
collapsing as a structure but not
pulling on the fingers and not pushing
on the thumb do you guys understand his
grip is training me his grip is training
me staying perfectly inside the circle
of that grip relaxing I started to get
it smaller and smaller do you see that
small or smaller I already have them
stuck on stuck on me so
I guess this is what I'm focusing on is
the dishy okay use those as a union Yong
to stay inside the middle of it okay so
as as noggin right I always have to work
on my structure and we don't want to
waste 50% of our time not working on our
structure and when we go when we go very
hard we throw intensely that structure
is what keeps you safe
it's also that structure that allows you
to martially counter something okay
but we know we break structure because
we are unconscious of it we have a kind
of unconscious ignorance going on right
where we know we break structure out of
fear
we don't want what's it but we don't
know what's going to happen so first
person that kind of breaks our Center
from their corners they can't cause
problems with you so you can stay here
but if I go here so he that's why he's
he's ready to push right he he can push
from where he's at right and as he has
the body released again where you're not
pushing but you had the body for pushing
right and I stay inside that that place
and just relax I'm gonna get him moving
in those subtle ways DC but
you have this disconnect and so you go
to push and we see you start to lean
okay say you're not ready you're not
ready to push so okay so the same thing
if I go if I go to push to you there's
there's a lag do you guys understand
that all right so it's not good training
for you for me it's joint training
because there are some people I don't
know they do do that all right so I
still tasked myself with the same thing
I have the fingers and the thumb okay
and I'm going to get that corpse pose
going inside the fingers and the thumb
and she's gonna disconnect and so when
she just connects eventually she's gonna
just fall over and you go ahead you're
fine
do you know what you're doing right now
no no no you're you're bracing on me
just stand over yourself stand over
yourself there you go grip okay stand
over yourself and I just do this
[Music]
what do you do right
you're leaving them man okay which is
fine that's we want to get there right
because go push right it can't always be
that you're pushing on me but I can make
you want to push on me do you guys
understand that so that's that's what I
do want to get there but I want to make
this point right now that someone who
disconnects their Center see she's
tilted now you see that and you just
wait you have it Dixie and so when she
goes when she does start to tilt right
so I keep myself with my task that my
teacher gave me and when she starts to
tilt and she doesn't what do you not
want to happen you don't want to fall so
now you're starting to push on me do you
see it go ahead don't you start to push
on me and now you can project out okay
so I I want you as a dish I'm going to
give you the task hey work on structure
okay but you must not eiated the death
scene is dogged I don't want you to go
hey she's just she's disconnecting and
then you start finding it something
going understand I want you to
understand that you you did you did what
happened you did what happened what you
want to happen so I got her team c9
you're leaning you're pushing on me
again okay go ahead which is fine right
because I think that's probably more but
the skill I wanted you to do was not to
you push and pull on that okay I got you
again
it's in the correction that's fine I got
you
so yeah here's where I want to go with
this now is I don't want you to think
that okay I don't want you to think that
you're you're doing an obvious
biomechanical shift right
what I'm doing is exactly what you saw
over there so it's the it's the
relationship right I get a senator
center relationship where what I do
FEX what you do okay so what she did was
the easy one is to push these pushes on
me she's using me for support then you
know that one right okay this one is a
little harder because I I want him not
to I don't want to handle a lean on me
okay but that's a very natural instinct
and that's a huge part of Japanese
jiu-jitsu oh I get senator senator
connection means you're at you're
relying on me for balance hey thanks for
giving me your balance right okay so
he's really screwed he's screwing with
me but he's gonna be a mountain that's
just doing its own thing and I'm going
to control the mountain okay got it
okay so yes let's start moving away from
the obvious you know what I'm saying so
it's just I keep using the fingers the
fingers to stay inside happily happily
happily happily happily
I believe okay go on
right so wool that's how I'm using it
now to move him well okay here it is
right here so well I don't want to leave
him out there and go boom booms you see
how high he's standing okay and I don't
want to do the obvious tricks and that's
stupid right so I have the same I am
taking the first drill we were doing
combining it with the second drill do
you see what we're doing there and now
okay don't come in now now we're going
to task him with that and I'm going to
use this this one
now get everything feel look till
you feel it right but that's what you're
noticing that when when you go a little
harder go a little harder we're like
really really hard it's not just that
he's coming at me and then I see that
because you're gonna stop him might be
that so and it can't be as effective as
he pushing at me and then I'm of you
know he down he did not commit so
there's there's gonna be the relaxation
the relaxation the relaxation is what's
pulling them in that corpse pose
relaxation not a structural
disappearance so I'm going to try to
work on the first trill keep using the
thumb and the finger corpse pose
relaxation then the other hand is good
it you'll feel where that was not gonna
do anything anymore right if you need to
go ahead remove your body and now you're
on the other drill don't move don't move
don't move
and I relaxed and you see I'm not doing
that right and then now now this would
be where the fight starts hey I'll take
that fight so relax relax stay inside
the fingers wait wait keep relaxing
inside the fingers cuz he's now tilted
so he's falling right so I leave that
there and then we'll start the next row
and I'll pick up on this arm and the
same thing don't move don't move but
he's fought he's at an angle right don't
move don't move but you'll give him his
balance back you understand that so if
we can hang if I push on him I'll give
him his balance back and we'll hang out
all day because his basis support
increased to mine so I had to relax and
you see he was falling so you have to
let him fall you have to let him fall
let him fall he's let him father and
then that's where you drop your weight
okay let's try
remember that hand has to stay in front
you're too high man your knees
[Music]
don't pull we're not doing TV now good
just doing that same drill from
different starting points laces reaction
listed push-up was to brace herself with
my base of support right
okay so so I start the initial one right
and then he wants to he wants to lean I
can feel him and I feel do you feel that
tightness there because he's using me
already
all right that's right I have him but if
I go like this huh and I don't let him
lean on me then I don't really have
control right so what I what I'm doing
is yeah
there I am and I want and when I feel
the hook as I going around it you see
and that gets him moving right and now
he's right here is where he wants to go
you feel that runner so again if I stay
right here he will keep his balance but
look what I'm doing
you see and I'm moving like that and
that's no different from their first
part you see you you're not going like
this you're going around energy alright
I'm just using it tactically now whoa oh
there it is he won't even now he wants
to push on me right so I go okay come on
you know then there goes right there he
wants to put okay come on and he wants
to push up my chin my chin on my arm
right so again if he leans on me gum ego
we're gonna hang out here all day but
when he's trying to push on me do you
see
oh those little steps are what's missing
from your technique those are all hip
having the chair pulled out from under
him right there
that's right that's where you're holding
your balance right now okay
so I will move you see now you're trying
to now you're trying to hook it right
there you see so I want that hook to
start working for me and I just resist
the temptation right
they're just right there on the shoulder
to see that and when I move it then
you'll fall so that was this gymnastics
thing I was just fine right you're gonna
you're gonna do the exercise for me
right there there just feel it so when I
take it away the same thing goes on the
grip right it's not all the way away
because then hey I need you to wanna
fall
[Music]
feel what she's hooking you now so enter
more with the left foot and get around
that enter with your left foot or not
left foot opposite of your right foot -
hi - hi
they inside the fingers till you get her
wanting to lean on you she's hooking she
hooked you that's what you want
alright let's let's look at this there's
the surface of Oklahoma okay so so if I
if I want to to trip him or let's even
start here okay so I want I want to kick
him in the in the head you got it so I
keep set boom I keep setting him up
right oh and I get his mind to go to
that to the head then fake and I like
I'll come around to the face you see
that no different than the Three Stooges
right so I've over here boom right you
captured his mind so no different if if
we go to grappling right I'm pulling
them with fighting right you see how I
pulled back okay so I pull he pulls back
and then I go in basic judo's concept
got it same thing here this is the same
thing I got him to pull on me I got him
to brace on me you understand and so
when he goes to pull when he goes to
brace off me
right that's where I that's where I'm
going to not use that my taking it away
get him do one thing so you can do
something else
but I have to stop bracing him back
right so for example I go to pull and he
pulls back and I do that do you see that
you just you lost your chance okay
so boom come on what you see right no
that's fine right so you didn't want you
didn't want that anymore but you started
this one if you pay attention do you
feel that pressure ok so then I'm slow
when I use you see that's the one I use
here it is over here on this hand a lot
of you guys take away that that arm
that's the one I use he feels it right
he's now trying to use that inside of my
other arm do you see you see I'm doing
that now you know let's try be closer
you can't see how I'm doing it
same constant God earns you now pushing
it right but you're doing it with the
key boss don't do anything
they still don't give me any momentum
right ok she's gonna start you so she's
already starting to feel that like me so
I have to keep using that keep using it
I'm moving it around oh yes you did ok
epidemic has done see the other arm
comes in not to kill her so she tries
she choices do you see how you went
right to it
ok so it's same thing look I go around
the energy you see I'm feeling my elbow
on you see that ok so I feel stay there
use it use it ok use it there you go
now it going around the energy right
using the hard ones
Hey oh there it is okay oh I'm going
around I'm using that you see why I did
that right and - now you're using it
this way do you see that so when I you
guys are like how do I get out and you
want to go like that
all right right where she's gonna feel
that she's falling right and then good
look what you did
you think she let go and she took this
hook down you see you see if we can hang
out here all day right okay so I gotta
get inside that that leverage point you
see how I'm doing that so you're just
doing that old judo's kids tricks I push
you're gonna pull and then I'm gonna set
you up okay
so whom do you see there you gave it to
me okay and then my relax you're gonna
find the new one do you see where you're
finding it yeah there it is okay thank
you got city we knock it right there
[Music]
so that's that's the drill I want I want
to get them to want to support on me
and then I set them up when I'm going to
pull the chair out hey have a seat
it's just that right but I can't
remember it at any point so if you if
you want to come in and hit me
you're gonna hear not that right boom my
body's not that pressure built up okay
so saw fine fine go okay choose that
right keep it slow though Jack still up
steady now so she's pulling right let's
just do you you're gonna come in
whatever yep okay so same thing here
whoa he's using me hi do you see it's
alright don't worry
there it is what you doing back it's
fine I just want you to play with it go
right right right
[Music]
right Vijay how we got your lifting here
right do you feel that you feel that
right right here right there
don't just do that come and come and do
different things hi hello we want we
want to set ourselves up for it there it
is right there you see it right here
she doesn't want my arm to go up right
okay so let it go down same thing he
didn't want it to come in right okay I
go around this you didn't want it to go
up again do you think he didn't want it
doesn't want it to go out that's the one
I use you see you didn't want it to go
up let it go down right
you can do try to get me still try to
get me good you're good okay same thing
look same thing you don't wanted to go
[Music]
same thing right good right you feel
that relax
right relax
oh he doesn't want to have to undergo
okay go around it
[Music]
same thing you didn't wanted to say to
go down let it come on they need sorry
yeah right there right right wherever
you feel his his base contact yours you
have
okay play with it just a movement drill
lock your frame your wrestling your
wrestling bat wrestling nut let's not
slam wrestling
[Applause]
so go back go back go back right there
okay conscious relaxation
I will not pull on four push on what's
pulling or pushing on me I've on it I'm
gonna set her up with that
okay
great now let's get a voucher again the
gross level understanding so he's gonna
let's do it again having some little
aggression so right here when I took
that step not dead right you want to set
it up from the get-go cool my god him
right he's holding off he's holding on
to me right there
so I don't want you to ten still us
weird I've heard that before huh okay so
[Music]
well you're giving this balance by all
those unnatural elbow phases because
you're pushing on her and you're just
giving a balance back
conscience don't push back on him
consciously relax
feel with her pushing set them up with
it okay so where do you wear it where do
you feel her weight
where is she leaning on Leah what are
you embracing on okay so you got so
that's what you don't want to push on
you want to use a spiral a relaxation to
get rid of it I don't know about that
one don't forget the drill we're working
on you don't need techniques
so I think for drilling this you
shouldn't use techniques because as a
desti you're like going oh who knows you
know how to do tension dog right so just
keep the drill
[Music]
so that you can tie disconnect just be
more patient they're off balance that's
why they're just connected you have that
mushy relaxation that's not it that's
not IQ
where is he pushing yes better you want
her to attack you said corpse pose relax
I gave my that was PJ I'm going Mimi
relax that's better
feel learnis you guys are still just
schoolyard grappling feel her balance
you trying to do technique
give him something to lean on
okay start shortening up your two hand
attacks hi you don't sit there and come
like you have you're a Texas Longhorn
bull with these big-ass horns okay
same drill go should be just like the
second level good
don't shove her you're trying to work on
something start them from closer don't
start them from across the bot whoa did
you feel that clash
[Music]
change levels use what he's leaning on
watch how many steps you're taking
[Music]
No
okay so we're in here what makes what
makes this look like a clinches because
I stayed not because he did it we'll
start here and he goes I stayed high he
goes to keep that in mind you're not
you're not moving okay
you're not moving
[Music]
that's right it's right here
right go around and see what I'm doing
right he's right here right and he's
coming back come back where I feel where
she's holding
yeah that's we're not doing techniques
we're drilling for energy that's all
we're doing drilling for energy
[Music]
do you feel that you come back that way
that is fun though age when you're with
her she is continually countering
because she's disconnecting which is
fine but for our drills perfect it's
still energy right here she's leaning on
me okay that's energy rebalance no
you're fine do it
rebalance no you're fun
why don't you do what you don't do okay
you're fine don't worry
so I would train with someone slower
when I'm working with this person to
stay in the drum I'm gonna kill you
right look what I'm doing then it's back
here
thank you all right